hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid gestern ist in
den USA was ziemlich historisches
passiert denn das gab es noch nie der
Republikaner Kevin McCarthy hat in einer
Abstimmung sein Amt als Sprecher des US
Repräsentantenhauses verloren die
Abgeordneten haben mehrheitlich für
einen Antrag des rechten heartliners mat
GZ gestimmt mccathy von der Spitze der
Kongresskammer zu stürzen ja und mccathy
der selber bei den Republikanern ist hat
damit einen parteiinternen Machtkampf im
Streit um die Haushaltspolitik verloren
und wurde als erster Repräsentantenhaus
Vorsitzender der ganzen usgeschichte
abgesetzt da sehen wir ihn wie er das
Haus verlässt ja und die rechte Gruppe
um matgz wirf dem Vorsitzenden des
Repräsentantenhauses vor er habe bei der
Abstimmung gemeinsame Sache mit den
Demokraten gemacht und damit gegen
fraktionsinterne Abspr Sprachen
verstoßen ja das sagt übrigens mat Getz
das ist der Anführer einer achtmann
starken ziemlich Rechten
trumpanhängerschaft im
Repräsentantenhaus und das hat er über
seinen eigenen Parteikollegen mccathy
gesagt kevin mccary ist Teil des Sumpfes
er hat für seinen Aufstieg Geld von
speziellen Interessengruppen gesammelt
und dann hat er dieses Geld im Austausch
für Gefälligkeiten verteilt wir
bekämpfen jetzt dieses Fieber und wir
sollten einen besseren Sprecher
wählen ja ganz schön harte Töne über
einem Parteikollegen in Washington ist
man jetzt erstmal ratlos und ganz viele
fragen sich jetzt was bedeutet dieses
Chaos für US-Präsident Joe Biden
inwiefern steckt Trump auch dahinter
inwiefern ist die usweltmacht ihr seht
schon hinter mir jetzt gelämt und vor
allem was bedeutet das alles für die
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
über all das sprechen wir heute bei ZDF
heute live und wie immer tu ich das
nicht alleine sondern mit Gästen wir
sprechen mit ZDF Korrespondent Elma
tavison der uns live aus Washington
zugeschaltet ist wir sprechen mit USA
Expertin Katherine Küver ashbrook von
der Bertelsmannstiftung und wie immer
sprechen wir auch mit euch wenn ihr
Fragen oder Anmerkungen zum Thema habt
dann schickt die wie immer gerne einfach
hier in den Youtube Chat oder per Mail
an die unten eingeblendete Adresse ich
freue mich auf euren Input jetzt
schalten wir aber erstmal nach
Washington zum Ort des Geschehens live
zu Emma tvison hallo
Emma hallo Victoria grüß Dich
Emma schätz uns das mal ein wie
besonders ist diese Abwahl und warum
richten sich jetzt mccathys eigene
Parteikollegen gegen ihn das macht ja
erstmal gar keinen
Sinn ja also erstmal ist es historisch
es gab zwar schon mal versuche früher
aber es ist nie wirklich gelungen einen
Sprecher des Abgeordneten Hauses dann
seines Amtes zu entheben auf diese Weise
vor allen Dingen durch seine eigene
Partei also historisch erstmalig
geschehen und das hat damit zu tun dass
mefi ja schon Schwierigkeiten hatte ins
Amt zu kommen er hat 15 Wahlgänge im
Januar gebraucht um dann der Sprecher
des des Hauses werden zu können und
dafür musste er Zugeständnisse machen
gegenüber eben diesen radikalen
innerhalb der eigenen Fraktion das hat
er gemacht einige haben sich dann damals
zwar nicht gegen ihn gewendet sondern
nur enthalten und haben ihm aber klar
gemacht er müsse das tun was sie wollen
damit er eben nicht wieder ein
Misstrauensvotum bekommt und dann hat er
im Juni dieses Jahres zugestimmt einem
Deal mit dem amerikanischen Präsidenten
Joe Biden da ging es darum ob man die
Schuldenobergrenze für die USA erhöht
damit also das Geld was man schon
beschlossen hat auch weiter ausgegeben
werden darf und innerhalb dieses Deals
hat McCafe eben auch einige
Zugeständnisse gemacht an Joe Biden
umgekehrt der auch an ihn aber damit
waren die Rechten in der Partei extrem
unzufrieden und jetzt im Grunde genommen
der entscheidende Punkt am vergangenen
Samstag als ein shutdown drohte von der
US-Regierung ein Stillstand spricht dass
keine Gelder mehr freigegeben werden aus
dem alten Haushalt solange man nicht
einen neuen Haushalt verabschiedet hier
in den USA dieser shutdown wurde
abgewendet weil McCafe ein Gesetz
eingebracht hat ein übergangsgesetz um
für die nächsten 45 Tage das ist bis zum
17 November sicherzustellen dass Gelder
weiter fließen können und zwar
prozentual in dem Umfang wie vorher eben
schon wie bisher und das haben die
radikalen in der republikanischen
Fraktion als Verrat als zweiten Verrat
angesehen und unter Führung von mgz
haben sie ihn haben Sie Kevin mccf cffi
dann eben gestern
gestürzt ja äh einen Sturz hinein in
eine kann man so sagen in einen
politischen Stillstand was bedeutet denn
dieser politische Stillstand jetzt für
diesen Haushaltsstreit den du gerade
schon angesprochen hast und diese Mittel
noovember drohende
Haushaltssperre ja das macht so
unglaublich schwierig wir hatten hier
vorhin Gelegenheit mit Jim McGovern zu
reden das ist ein demokratischer
Abgeordneter aus massachusets der uns
gesagt hat das bedeutet absolute
Handlungsunfähigkeit solange nicht ein
neuer Sprecher tatsächlich gewählt wird
und das bedeutet wenn sich das länger
hinzieht möglicherweise auch bis zum 17
November dann kann mit diesem Datum eben
tatsächlich es zu diesem shutdown der
Regierung kommen das heißt keinerlei
Gelder stehen mehr zur Verfügung für die
Regierungsarbeit bis auf ganz wenige
essentielle Bereiche und das würde im
Umkehrschluss auch bedeuten dass keine
zusätzlichen neuen Militärhilfen
verabschiedet werden können für die
Ukraine das würde den US-Präsidenten
massiv unterduck setzen momentan hat er
noch aus den 45 Milliarden Dollar die
der Kongress schon genehmigt hat einige
Spielräume um weiterhin Waffen Munition
an die Ukraine zu geben aber er braucht
dringend eine Erweiterung um weitere 20
Milliarden so wird hier gesagt ist auch
der Vorschlag und das kann aber nur
passieren wenn man sich eben auf einen
neuen Haushalt für das nächste Jahr
verständigt und das wollen die radikalen
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
verhindern weil sie fordern sehr große
Kürzungen innerhalb dieses
Haushaltsgesetzes das betrifft nicht nur
die ukrainehilfe sondern das betrifft
vor allen Dingen auch einige
Sozialprogramme z.B ein Programm mit dem
hier ärmere Schulen in den USA
Unterstützung bekommen das soll um 80%
gekürzt werden 14 Milliarden mal eben
rausgestrichen das wä für viele Schulen
im ganzen Land sicherlich fatal in den
ärmeren Gegenden also da sind die
radikalen eigentlich nicht
kompromissbereit und deswegen dürfte
sehr spannend sein ob man überhaupt
einen neuen Sprecher des Hauses finden
kann der bereit ist diese maximal
Forderungen der radikalen dann auch zu
erfüllen ja wir hören radikale
Forderungen wir haben Druck auf den
US-Präsidenten der Demokrat ist und wir
haben auch zerschritten Hal innerhalb
der republikanischen Partei wem nützt
dieses Chaos denn jetzt
innerpolitisch na das nützt zunächst mal
den radikalen unmittelbar selber weil
die werden in ihren eigenen Wahlkreisen
dafür gefeiert zwar nicht von allen aber
doch von der großen Mehrheit ihrer
Unterstützer weil sie eben glauben diese
Unterstützer dass die Abgeordneten genau
das tun für was Sie hier nach Washington
geschickt worden sind nämlich dafür zu
sorgen dass Verschwendung aus ihrer
Sicht aufhört dass man eben massiv
Gelder zusammenstreicht für Programme
die diese ich sag mal rechten idiologen
rechtskonservativen eben nicht
unterstützen sie wollen dafür dass
andere Programme finanziert und
unterstützt werden sie werden also
Vorteile davon haben diese radikalen sie
werden gefeiert aber im Rest der
republikanischen Partei ist das Echo
natürlich schon sehr unterschiedlich es
gibt hier Abgeordnete beispielsweise
auch hier aus dem Repräsentantenhaus von
der republikanischen Partei die sagen
das gestern war der Verrat dass Matt GZ
den Sprecher mccafi gestürzt hat und da
sind im Grunde genommen die Gräben auch
zwischenreublikanischen Abgeordneten im
Kongress so tief dass ich glaube viele
Unterstützer von mccafy einige haben
gestern übrigens in der Fraktionssitzung
dann auch geweint als er gesagt hat er
würde nicht wieder antreten wollen als
Sprecher also nicht noch mal einen
Versuch starten dass diese die so
enttäuscht und frustriert und verärgert
sind über die radikalen auch nicht
bereit sind einen dieser radikalen dann
möglicherweise nächste Woche hier zum
Sprecher zu wählen und das ist jetzt das
große Problem der Republikaner sie
müssen beweisen dass sie überhaupt in
der Lage sind eine Führung zu finden
Gesetzesvorhaben einzubringen
voranzubringen regierungsfähig zu sein
und dafür müssen sie sich auf
irgendeinen Kandidaten verständigen der
bereit ist Kompromisse zu machen und
zwar gegen über den acht Radikalen die
hier Kevin mccarfy gestern gestürzt
haben ich werf gerade mal so ein Blick
in den Chat und unsere User und Userin
haben ziemlich viele Fragen dazu eine
die hier immer wieder auftaucht ist
folgende wäre es aus Sicht der
Demokraten nicht sinnvoll gewesen für
McCarthy zu stimmen um ihn im Amt zu
halten und einen möglichen shutdown zu
verhindern ja das ist offenbar innerhalb
der Demokratischen Partei auch
diskutiert worden hinter verschlossenen
Türen aber hinterher hat Hakim jeffre
dann klar gesagt nein man würde Kevin
McCarthy nicht mitwählen und das hat
einfach Gründe weil Kevin McCarthy als
einer der Unterstützer von Donald Trump
auch nach dem 6 Januar 2021 gilt er hat
sich zwar in den ersten Stunden nach
diesem Sturm aufs Kapitol hier hinter
uns distanziert davon hat aber in den
Tagen danach dann sehr schnell im
grundeum einen 180° Schwenk gemacht hat
sich mit Donald Trump getroffen gilt als
einer der Anhänger und auch ich sag mal
büchsenspanner von Donald Trump hier in
Washington und das haben ihm die
Demokraten nicht verziehen dass er im
Grunde genommen das was am 6 Januar hier
passiert ist verharmlost hat und sie
haben ihm auch nicht verziehen dass er
eben in den letzten Monaten jedenfalls
wenig bereit war Kompromisse
voranzutreiben stattdessen aber dafür
gesorgt hat dass zugunsten der hartliner
hier
Untersuchungsausschüsse gegen Joe Biden
gegen seinen Sohn und die
Geschäftsbeziehungen die dieser hatte
hier aufgemacht worden sind also aus
Sicht der Demokraten kein Grund Kevin
kffi zu unterstützen das schließt nicht
aus dass die Demokraten nicht am Ende
bereit wären vielleicht doch einen
Republikaner zu unterstützen der hier
antritt wenn es ein Moderator wäre
allein um einen Keil in die
republikanische Partei zu treiben aber
wir haben wie gesagt vorhin hier mit
jimcgavn geredet einem demokratischen
Abgeordneten der auch das eigentlich für
extrem unwahrscheinlich oder
ausgeschlossen bezeichnet hat weil er
eben der Meinung ist wir sind nicht dazu
da den Republikanern zu verhelfen zu
zeigen dass sie am Ende doch
verantwortungsvoll handeln können
und wir haben hier noch eine Frage zu
dem vorübergehenden Haushalt den du auch
schon angesprochen hast Sven odendall
fragt wird die Einigung über den
vorübergehenden Haushalt jetzt Bestand
haben oder ist zu erwarten dass auch
diese Absprachen noch mal gekippt werden
könnten also es steht zu erwarten dass
das Bestand hat 45 Tage seit letzten
Samstag das heißt 17 November ist dann
der Stichtag wir gehen davon aus dass
das Bestand hat jetzt kommt das aber
ausschließend kann man offenbar hier
nichts mehr nachdem wir auch gestern ein
historisches first erlebt haben wie man
das hier so nennt das heißt es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass vielleicht
irgendeiner gewählt wird nächste Woche
zum Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses
der gewissermaßen als Wahlprogramm
seinen Anhängern vermittelt in der
Fraktion dass man diese vorübergehende
Einigung kippt ich glaube das aber eher
nicht das hat damit zu tun dass schon im
Land auch wahrgenommen wird dass äh das
Land ins Chaos zu stürzen äh jetzt im
grundeum zu sorgen dafür dass die
Regierung schließen muss in weiten
Teilen jedenfalls dass nichts mehr
vorangeht und auch nicht die
republikanischen Vorhaben vorangehen
können das damit kann man keine
Pluspunkte in weiten Teilen des Landes
sammeln also ich vermute doch es wird
Bestand haben bis zum 17 November aber
was dann passiert ob es ein Haushalt für
das nächste Jahr gibt und wieder
aussieht das ist völlig offen ja viele
offene Fragen und auch was du schon
angesprochen hast nämlich der weite
Blick der mittelfristige Blick auf
nächstes Jahr auf das
präsidentschaftswahljahr in den USA
beschäftigt unsere Community hier fragt
Dennis von derbeck auf Facebook wie
wirkt sich dieses Durcheinander auf die
Stimmung der Bevölkerung im Bezug auf
die Präsidentschaftswahlen
aus also wir haben noch keine aktuellen
Umfragen zu der zu dem Punkt was
passiert jetzt im Land was die Stimmung
angeht auch basierend auf dem was
gestern passiert ist der tatsächliche
Sturz von Kevin mccafee aber wir wissen
aus allen Umfragen der letzten Wochen
und Monate dass die Amerikaner quer
durch die die Parteien die Arbeit des
Kongresses als extrem kritisch ansehen
Sie der Meinung sind dass dieses Land
eher durch diese Polarisierung auch
behindert wird dass man nicht vorankommt
allerdings gibt's eben auch auf beiden
Seiten bei Demokraten und Republikaner
Anhänger derer die meinen nein man darf
sich auf keine Kompromisse mit der
jeweiligen anderen Seite einlassen ich
glaube am Ende ist dann nicht
entscheidend was irgendeine Umfrage
jetzt gerade mal sagt sondern das was
nächstes Jahr bei den Wahlen an der
Wahlurne für eine Situation ist und das
spielt eine ganz große Rolle ob
beispielsweise die wirtschaftlichen
Vorhaben der beiden Administration das
riesige
infrastrukturpaket die Unterstützung
eben auch für den Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien und dabei werden
auch das haben wir gesehen im Land an
vielen Stellen neue Jobs geschaffen die
auch besser bezahlt sind als früher also
ob das Wirkung entfaltet und dann bei
den Wählern dazu führt dass sie sich
vielleicht für die Seite entscheiden die
eher Stabilität verspricht ob das so ist
wissen wir nicht wir haben aber ein paar
Anhaltspunkte dass auch wenn die
Umfragen der beiden Administration sehr
kritisch gegenüber waren in den letzten
Monaten sehen wir doch im Wahlverhalten
bei Zwischenwahlen vor einem Jahr aber
auch bei kleineren Wahlen in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten dass mit
überwältigender Mehrheit sich die
demokratischen Kandidaten durchgesetzt
haben das auch in Wahlkreisen wo es
eigentlich fiftyfifty stand die sich
durchgesetzt haben also am Ende scheinen
Wähler eher dazu zu tendieren die zu
wählen in die Ämter von denen sie
erwachten dass sie keine politischen
Spiele treiben sondern die Dinge auch
voranbringen
du hast es gerade schon kurz angerissen
Joe Biden kann ja durchaus einige
politische Erfolge vermelden und über
Joe Biden und seine ja Legacy bis jetzt
hast du eine Reportage fürs
auslandsjournal gemacht und da gucken
wir jetzt mal rein bidens Bündnispolitik
gilt als höchst erfolgreich gerade erst
waren die Anführer der Inselstaaten des
Pazifik zu Gast beiden will Chinas
Einfluss eingrenzen und den von Russland
deshalb war wododomia selenski da vorher
hatte sich der US-Präsident in New York
mit Russlands zentralasiatischen
Nachbarn getroffen beiden mag
zerbrechlich wirken wie bei seinem
historischen Besuch im kommunistischen
Vietnam aber die Schlagzahl seiner
diplomatischen Initiativen ist hoch der
Generalsekretär der Kommunistischen
Partei ist übrigens jünger als der
US-Präsident der hinterher bei der
Pressekonferenz offenärzig
sagt ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
iche
bet ja beiden fällt schon mal zum
Schrecken seiner Beratung die haben ihm
jetzt tägliche Gleichgewichtsübungen
verordnet er soll häufiger tonschuhe
tragen und wenn er einen starken
Auftritt
hat wollen sie hinterher sicherstellen
dass so
etwas den Eindruck nicht verwessert der
Präsident sei seinem Amt jederzeit
gewachsen sagen
sie ja und die ganze Reportage der
greisepräsident findet ihr in der ZDF
Mediathek und wir verlinken euch die
auch noch mal hier in der Infobox ja
wir haben es gerade in deinem Beitrag in
deinem Stück gesehen es gibt einige
politische Erfolge aber die USA hängen
sich immer wieder an der Frage auf ist
dieser Mann eigentlich zu alt für dieses
wichtige Amt was wirft das denn jetzt
überhaupt alles für ein Licht auf Joe
Biden wie geht der denn gerade aus
dieser Sache raus bzw was für ein
Einfluss hat diese Blockade auf den
Präsidenten also zunächst mal noch mal
zu dem Alter kann man sagen es gibt
gerade eine neue Umfrage die heute
veröffentlicht wurde von National Public
Radio das ist öffentlich rechtliches
Fernsehen und Radio hier in den USA und
die kommen zu dem Schluss dass ja eine
große Mehrheit der Wähler auf beiden
Seiten hält Joe Biden für zu alt aber
auch Donald Trump für zu alt eigentlich
um Präsident zu sein für die nächste
Amtszeit aber wenn man dann eben fragt
und das wurde auch da und in vielen
anderen Umfragen getan wie sieht es bei
den einzelnen Themen aus die nachher die
Wahl entscheiden weshalb man dann sein
Kreuzchen an der ein oder anderen Stelle
macht da sagen die Wähler dass sie doch
eine hohe Zufriedenheit haben übrigens
auch zwei Drittel bis dreiviertel
innerhalb der Demokratischen Partei mit
dem was Joe Biden in den letzten 3i
Jahren hier bisher vorantreiben konnte
also man findet ihn zu alt würde sich
einen jüngeren wünschen aber viele
denken eben auch es gibt momentan
niemand anders der in der lag wäre das
Land voranzutreiben und vielleicht auch
Donald Trump am Ende zu besiegen was
heißt das was hier passiert jetzt gerade
ich glaube es bestätigt viele in dem
Eindruck dass die republikanische Partei
wenn sie so zerstritten ist wenn die
sich gegenseitig im Grunde genommen
erledigen dass die eigentlich nicht
regierungsfähig ist also es wird die
Anhänger der demokratischen Parteien
Stück weit bestärken Joe Biden ist immer
noch handlungsfähig im Weißen Haus auch
wenn hier sich im Repräsentantenhaus
nicht viel tut Außenpolitik wird
mehrheitlich vom Senat hier gleich
nebenan entschieden in den USA ähm
natürlich hängen bestimmte Gelder auch
an dem was im Abgeordnetenhaus passiert
aber der Präsident hat in den nächsten
Monaten weiterhin Handlungsmöglichkeiten
mit den bisher vorhandenen Geldern die
dann weiter ausgegeben werden könnten
und der Präsident könnte sogar wenn er
wollte und es drauf anlegt wenn hier
Stillstand bleibt schlicht und
ergreifend aus eigenerig sag mal
überschwitzt Machtvollkommenheit
entscheiden er gibt das Geld weiter aus
weil ja der amerikanische Kongress schon
mal für die Ausgabe dieser Gelder
gestimmt hat und dann müsste am Ende
irgendjemand klagen und vor dem Obersten
Gericht auch hier gleich um die Ecke
müsste am Ende die Entscheidung gefällt
werden ob ein Präsident so etwas darf
also er ist momentan jedenfalls weiter
handlungsfähig aber es ist natürlich für
alle Beteiligten wichtig dass man
möglichst schnell hier wieder zu einer
Arbeitsfähigkeit kommt und das könnte
frühstens nächste Woche Mittwoch
passieren wenn man hier über einen neuen
Sprecher oder eine Sprecherin abstimmen
will Emma danke schön für diese ersten
Analysen live aus Washington und dir
noch einen schönen ich sage es mal nicht
Abend sondern
Tag danke schön liebe Grüße nach
Deutschland danke schön ja so viel
erstmal zu den Folgen dieser Abwahl in
den USA für die Wahl die nächstes Jahr
ansteht und über die aber auch über die
Symbolkraft dieses Vorgangs über die
us-grenzen hinaus ihr seht ja hinter mir
Weltmacht die USA sind immer noch eine
große Weltmacht spreche ich jetzt mit
USA a Expertin Katherine Küver asbruck
von der bertzmannstiftung die mir LIVE
zugeschaltet ist guten Abend guten Abend
nach me
hallo ja auch die Frage an Sie noch mal
was für ein Signal geht von dieser
Blockade aus auch mit Blick auf die
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 gucken wir
mal auf das republikanische Lager weil
der der diesen Antrag eingebracht hat
mat GZ der ist ja Teil einer
achtköpfigen Gruppe die sich als ja
glühende Trump Verehrer verstehen wie
blickt denn Trump auf diese Blockade ja
Trump sätt weiterhin Chaos in seinen
sozialen Media Medienkanälen selbst wenn
er gerade ein bisschen beschäftigt ist
weil ihm gerade in New York gerade
wieder einen Prozess gemacht wird da
geht's natürlich um hauptsächlich seine
geschäftlichen Probleme bzw über die
Beschönigung seines Geschäftsvolumens
und dennoch hält es sie nicht davon ab
in die sozialen Medien zu rein
reinzuschreiben dass er gerne ein
komplettes Chaos gesehen hätte eine
komplette Blockade er hatte den
Republikanern in der Haushaltsdebatte
empfohlen
quasi das Land ja auflaufen zu lassen
wenn man so möchte und es erinnert
natürlich an die schweren Zeiten in den
Trump Jahren woüber 30 Tage lang Amerika
quasi handlungsunfähig war nämlich einen
der längsten historischen shutdowns hat
ein Donald Trump zu verantworten und
das hat ihm also er ist ein Mann der vom
Chaos lebt und er hat die Republikaner
und bzw natürlich seine seine Anhänger
quasi in diesem Chaos sehen in dem was
jetzt manche einen Bürgerkrieg in der
republikanischen Partei nennen nur noch
ja aufgefordert weiterzumachen sie ähm
ja quasi
angetrieben und
das ist natürlich für die Partei an sich
jetzt erstmal ein ganz ganz schweres
Brot denn sie wird jetzt sie werden zwar
nicht handlungsfähig sein über die
nächste Woche aber in der
republikanischen Partei gerade in der
führungsrege wird sehr sehr viel
telefoniert werden um zu überlegen wie
kommt es jetzt wie kommt ein eine
Strategie zusammen die sie am Mittwoch
im in Washington präsentieren können ja
und ähnlich sieht das auch ein User der
uns gerade zuschaut Thomas renn schreibt
auf Facebook die Partei zerstört sich
selbst und ist völlig unfähig zu
regieren jetzt ist ja auch immer wieder
das Thema militärische Unterstützung der
Ukraine ein Thema hier bei uns in der
Sendung hier im Chat aber eben auch und
das deutet sich schon an in den USA im
Wahlkampf
2024 und jetzt hat man ja vor ein paar
Tagen diesen Nothaushalt verabschiedet
der hat keine weiteren Hilfe für die
Ukraine mehr dabei gehabt m jetzt hat
gestern Abend aber schon Joe Biden mit
Kanzler Scholz telefonieren mit
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von derline
mit natoensekretär Stoltenberg und hat
verkündet
diese bislang bewilligten Mittel die
würden noch ausgezahlt würden noch ein
paar Wochen oder ein paar Monate helfen
trotzdem ist das ja jetzt ein Signal was
da gerade von den USA aus ausgeht wir
wissen dass das wird den Wahlkampf 2024
prägen wie schätzen Sie das ein müssen
sich andere westliche Unterstützer der
Ukraine also die EU-Staaten nicht jetzt
schon Gedanken darüber machen wie man
ein mögliches ausfallen dieser
Unterstützung kompensieren könnte aus
eigenen Haushalten ja das müssen sie das
hätten sie eigentlich schon vorgestern
tun sollen wenn man so will also im Juni
ging es auf dem letzten Sondergipfel der
EU noch mal darum wie kann die
europäische friedensfazilität die sehr
interessant benannt ist noch stärker
dafür genutzt werden nicht nur die
europäischen mitgliedst en zu
kompensieren in ihrer Militärhilfe für
die Ukraine sondern umgekehrt gleich in
Vorlage zu gehen um gerade auch in der
Beschaffung quasi dafür zu sorgen dass
weiterhin das Gerät der Ukraine
zugeliefert wird was dann zeitig
gebraucht wird aber es wird lange lange
nicht reichen wenn die quasi die
Militärhilfe der Amerikaner zumindest zu
schwächeln scheint bzw nicht zeitig
ankommt emma teveson hat es im
Vorgespräch schon angesprochen es sind
noch Gelder da es sind keine kleinen
Summen 5 4 Milliarden Dollar können
jetzt gerade noch nicht nur zur Wartung
sondern auch zur Erneuerung des
militärischen Geräts eingesetzt werden
die jetzt quasi schon versprochen sind
es sind auch noch andere Gelder da die
der Präsident quasi verfügen kann die
schon die Genehmigung zum Teil des
Kongresses haben da gibt's
unterschiedliche finanzierungstöpfe und
unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten aus dem
Pentagon noch Gelder zu beziehen aber
der richtig große Wurf den er sich
gewünscht hat von diesem Kongress
es wurde immer von der ja der Ordnung
zwischen 20 bis 25 Milliarden Dollar
zusätzlichen Finanz spritz einer
zusätzlichen Finanzspritze gesprochen
das hat es eben so nicht gegeben aber
man muss noch mal betonen dass die
Mehrheit
des Kongresses 311 Abgeordnete weiterhin
indizieren sie sind stark dafür die
Ukraine in ihrem Kampf gegen Russland in
diesem Angriffs also in diesem
erniedrigungskampf den Russland der
Ukraine aufgezwungen hat ähm sich dort
weiter äh nach vorne zu positionieren
taktisch da weiterzumachen wo also jetzt
haben wir eine Änderung der ukrainischen
Strategie oder leichte Änderung der
ukrainischen Strategie gesehen und das
spielt den Amerikanern summer somarum in
die Hände das ist eine Taktik die die
Amerikaner sehen wollten das hat sich
auch ergeben aus den Gesprächen zwischen
Präsident selenski und beiden bzw der
Rede von selenski
im Kongress vor ungefähr 10 12 Tagen
also insgesamt ist der Kongress
jedenfalls mehrheitlich noch an der
Seite der Ukraine es wird aber nun
wirklich darum gehen wann kann eine
ukrainehilfe wirklich wieder verhandelt
werden wann kann man über wie man so
sagen möchte über Dollars und Cents
reden und wann kann dann diese Hilfe
wirklich in entsprechend umgesetzt
werden sowohl in das militärische Gerät
was gebraucht wird aber dann
längerfristig auch in andere Dinge wie
wirtschaftliche und finanzielle
Unterstützung ja und um uns das reine
Ausmaß dieser us-hilfen auf den
ukrainekrieg noch mal deutlich zu machen
haben wir eine Grafik für euch vor
vorbereitet die das ganz gut zeigt wie
wichtig die USA für die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine sind wir sehen
hier Unterstützung der Ukraine nach
Ländern 69,5 Milliarden Dollar haben die
USA mittlerweile unterstützt durch
finanzielle Hilfe aber durch auch durch
Waffen und ausrüung das ist der größte
Teil und einen Kleinteil humanitäre
Hilfe mal zum Vergleich Deutschland also
wir sind der zweitgrößte Unterstützer
aber mit 20,9 Milliarden natürlich weit
hinter den USA abgeschlagen es ist also
ganz essentiell für das weiterbehen der
Ukraine in diesem Angriffskrieg dass die
USA als großunterstützer bleiben und da
haben wir auch gleich eine Frage aus der
Community dazu hier fragt jemand wird
Europa überhaupt eine mögliche Lücke der
USA in der ukrainehilfe schließen können
also würde es ohne die USA überhaupt
gehen na jedenfalls nicht so wie gerade
die Hilfen getaktet sind bzw auch nicht
wie in der Schnelligkeit in der Gerät
geliefert werden kann wir haben immer
noch weiterhin in Europa auch wenn die
EU-Kommission wirklich durch ganz
unterschiedliche Initiativen in der
Beschaffung auf europäischer Ebene
nachgeholfen hat in vielen vielen
Ländern der Europäischen Union aber eben
der NATO NATO Mitgliedstaaten immer noch
ganz grundsätzliche Beschaffungsprobleme
und das was die USA leistet auch ganz g
ganz grundsätzlichen ähm waffenteilen
also wir denken noch mal an Artillerie
Munition die 1,55
155 Millimeter Kaliber Geschosse die
Artilleriemunition das ist das Herzstück
quasi des des engen Kampfes der
ukrainischen Truppen
quasi im Nahkampf im nahaustausch mit
den russischen Truppen und die werden zu
ganz großem Teil jedenfalls in einer
Geschwindigkeit inzwischen in Fabriken
in Pennsylvania und anderswo hergestellt
dass da können die europäischen ähm
Hersteller in dem Tempo jedenfalls nicht
mithalten und selbst bei den Amerikanern
ist eben sind bestimmte
munitionsgattungen sehr sehr eng
geworden wir erinneren uns an die
Kontroverse Entscheidung Streumunition
zu liefern an die Ukraine als Übergang
um dahinzukommen quasi traditionelle
Munition ab und auszulösen also ganz
klar ist die Situation und auch die
Lieferketten auf beiden Seiten sehr sehr
eng aber um das zu kompensieren was die
Amerikaner leisten wäre eine immense
Kraftanstrengung der Europäer nötig da
wir haben gerade die Haushaltsdebatte
hier im Bundestag erlebt dann müssten
auch über weitere Haushalte in der in
den europäischen mitgliedländern und neu
nachgedacht werden und es müsste vor
allen Dingen eben auch mit europäischen
Wählern noch anders kommuniziert werden
denn das wird genauso wie in den USA
Abschläge einfordern in anderen
Politikbereichen und darauf ist
jedenfalls bislang sind da europäische
Wähler und wie wir jetzt eben auch sehen
im Wahlkampf amerikanische Wähler erstes
Mal nicht richtig vorbereitet bzw auch
nicht mehr ganz gewillt in der
amerikanischen aus der amerikanischen
Perspektive einen Krieg mitzutragen der
in einer wahnsinnigen entfern ung zu den
USA stattfindet und der jetzt inzwischen
innenpolitisch so politisiert wird und
so quasi verglichen wird mit
innenpolitischen Ausgaben das nicht mehr
ganz deutlich ist und das sehen wir in
den
Mehrheiten es gibt keine 50prozentige
Mehrheit mehr unter der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung diesen Krieg zu unterstützen
das heißt genau diese Diskussionen in
der Innenpolitik und das innenpolitische
instrumentalisieren des ukrainekrieges
wird für die Anführer der westlichen
Gemeinschaft für jo für Olaf Scholz für
Ursula von derlein sch Michelle und die
diversen Staatschefs des westlichen
Bündnisses jetzt die Hauptaufgabe der
nächsten Monate besonders in die harten
Wintermonate des des Kamps in der
Ukraine werden ja und da spielt
natürlich auch der Faktor Zeit eine
super wichtige Rolle das stellen wir
hier bei ZF he live ja immer wieder fest
wie blickt man denn jetzt im Kremmel
also in Russland auf dieses politische
Erdbeben in den USA welche Symbolkraft
hat das so Richtung Osten ne ich glaube
für Wladimir Putin wird wird diese
historische Entscheidung eines
republikanisch geführten Abgeordneten
Hauses ja ein politisches feigsen
ausgelöst haben anders kann ich mir das
fast gar nicht vorstellen denn seit der
Olympiade in soti aber dann natürlich
auch in den verschiedenen politischen
Reden hatte immer darauf hingewiesen
dass der moralische Verfall oder
überhaupt der Verfall der Werte der
Verfall des grundsätzlichen
Verständnisses von Demokratie und
Systemarchitektur dass ich quasi der
Westen aber eben sononders die USA quasi
selbst zerfleischen würde und wenn dann
umgekehrt selbst amerikanische
Berichterstatter eben von einem
Bürgerkrieg oder bürgerkriegsähnlichen
Zuständen innerhalb der republikanischen
Partei sprechen dann ist das doch für
ein Vladimir Putin ein gefundenes
Fressen wir können davon ausgehen und
das sehen wir schon an den Prognosen
dass z.B Desinformation in dem Wahlkampf
2024 besonders russisch gesteuerte
Desinformation aber auch Desinformation
aus China eine immer bedeutende Rolle
spielen wird KI gesteuerte
Desinformation
natürlich auch um Wähler Stimmen quasi
buolen wird und bzw versuchen wird
Wähler so zu verunsichern dass Sie erst
gar nicht zur Wahl gehen das sind die
ganz alten Taktiken die jetzt die
Russische Föderation umsetzt aber alte
Taktiken aus Sowjetzeiten und da sieht
Herr Putin jetzt natürlich erneute
Chancen auch haben die Republikaner vor
einigen Monaten beschlossen dass
Desinformation im Ganzen nicht quasi
komplett verwerflich sei besonders nicht
auf in den sozialen Medien nicht separat
gekennzeichnet wden werden müsse und
Elon Musk der sich vertret als Vertreter
aufgeschwungen hat des ersten
verfassungszusatzes in den USA sehr
freien
Meinungsäußerung verteidigt quasi diese
Entscheidung Desinformation nicht als
solche zu kennzeichnen das heißt hier
wird ein Weg geebnet für autoritäre
Mächte mit unter eben also natürlich
allen voran Wladimir Putin der ein
starkes Interesse daran hat dass ein
Republikaner ins Weiße Haus einzieht im
besten Fall einer der den Krieg in der
ukra in Anführungszeichen so schnell wie
möglich beenden möchte oder am ersten
Tag beenden möchte wie Donald Trump es
gesagt hat und der dann umgekehrt
Vladimir Putin und seinen Absichten für
die Ukraine nur in die Hände spielt und
wir haben h noch mal eine Frage aus der
Community zur Motivation dieser Debatte
die wir da gerade in den USA sehen uvo
mobil fragt auf Youtube würden die
Republikaner die Ukraine aufgeben
wollen das ist sehr interessant weil es
eine sehr sehr konkrete Antwort gegeben
hat in den zwei bish herig gehaltenen
Debatten um die republikanische
Präsidentschaftskandidatur und auch das
ist ja zumindest modern historisch dass
in quasi vorwahldebatten also wo es noch
nicht mal um den Run um den eigentlichen
run ums Weiße Haus geht wie in einer
republikanischen
innenparteilichen debattenserie die
Ukraine oder bzw ein außenpolitisches
Thema so
thematisiert wird und da haben wir von
verschiedenen Kandidaten gehört unter
anderem von Vivek ramoswami der sich
jetzt in den letzten Zeiten zumindest
prozentual einiges ausgerechnet hat
was eine Kandidatur angeht dass er
ja in der Tat versuchen würde sofort den
Krieg zu beenden und den Donbass
mindestens den Donbass an Russland
abzutreten also genau konterkarikiert
der der an der Pläne der Ukraine quasi
ihr gesamtes Territorium wieder
zurückzuholen inklusive der Krim also
wirklich eine quasi außenpolitische
Linie dafür ist er auch muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen auf der republikanischen
Bühne von anderen Kandidaten wieder ganz
scharf angegangen worden unter anderem
auch vom früheren Vizepräsidenten Mike
Pence aber es gibt Kandidaten die sehr
laut sind
und die quasi noch mal unterstreichen
sie würden den Krieg beenden indem Sie
Wladimir Putin direkt in die Hände
spielen und andere Optionen hat Donald
Trump in seinen Aussagen über den Krieg
in der Ukraine auch nicht abgezeichnet
also eine Kehrtwende zu einer ganz
traditionellen historisch antirussisch
antisowjet äh Logik geprägten Mentalität
einer republikanischen Partei der
sogenannten regagan Republicans die
quasi dieser freiheitskrampf dieses
Verständnisses des internationalen der
international internationalen Freiheit
die die USA in die Welt tragen wollte
das ist eine komplette Antithese und
auch da scheint sich die republikanische
Partei zumindest in Teilen quasi von
ihren Traditionen zu heuten ob das dann
zu einem Wahlerfolg führen kann bzw ob
sich ob das dann wirklich
außenpolitische Ziele Gesetz sind die
ein Land mittragen würde das ist eine
ganz andere
Frage und von dieser politischen
Blockade die ja der Aufhänger für diese
Sendung heute war gucken wir jetzt noch
mal ein Stück weit in die Zukunft und
Fragen abschließend aus der Community
was würde denn eine Trump
Präsidentschaft für den Westen und die
Weltordnung bedeuten könnten wir da
sogar von einem Ende der ushgemonie
ausgehen also ich glaube das ist
wirklich die Frage die im Raum steht wir
wissen über Donald Trumps zweite
Amtszeit dass er versuchen wird noch
aktiver die
us-demokratie in ihren Kernfunktionen zu
zersetzen es ging damit los mit der
Umbesetzung bzw der Besetzung mit
mehrheitlich konservativen re Richtern
im Obersten Gerichtshof die jetzt auch
wieder in den nächsten Monaten Fragen
zum Wahlrecht verhandeln werden es ging
um eine um das Einsetzen auf Lebenszeit
so vieler konservativer Richter wie die
USA es noch nie in der eigenen
Geschichte erlebt hat wir wissen jetzt
dass es ein großes Projekt GI Projekt
2050 getragen von Erz konservativen
Think Tanks in Washington mit der
Unterstützung von den ehemaligen
Chefstrategen der ersten Trump
Administration Steve Miller und
natürlich Steve Bannon ganz hinten
wirklich die die Bundesagenturen
auszumerzen und vor allen Dingen eben
auch die Bundesangestellten also den
ganzen Beamtenapparat einem Präsidenten
gefügig zu machen da ist normalerweise
das ist ein sehr sehr unabhängiges
System die wirklich natürlich ihre ja
ihre ihre Arbeitsleistung auf die
Verfassung der USA schwören und nicht
hörig gemacht werden können einem
Präsidenten also in einem Wahlprogramm
von Donald Trump
das steuert alles darauf hin dass es
eine quasi eine exekutiv
autoritäre ein exekutiv autoritäres
System in den USA geben könnte was eben
die rechte die Individualrechte und
alles das was die USA in ihrer
pluralistischen Ausrichtung historisch
ausmacht aber eben auch in der
Ankerfunktion als als kerndemokratie im
internationalen Rechtssystem wir denken
an die UN wir denken an die
internationalen Organisationen wie die
Welthandelsorganisation und andere in
der Glaubwürdigkeit ausmacht wenn die
USA als Garant für und wir haben in der
Trump Administration gesehen wie viel
Gelder im UN-System weggekürzt worden
sind
wie er anstatt über die
Welthandelsorganisation zu arbeiten
lieber alleinig handelszölle und andere
wirtschaftliche obligate in die Welt
ausgesprochen hat wie er America first
gesehen hat als Amerika allein und
Amerika anders als der Rest der Welt und
wenn die USA in diesem Sinne in ihrer
Kernfunktion in ihrer Ankerfunktion für
die internationale Weltordnung wegfällt
während sich auf der anderen Seite der
Welt über bricks also Brasilien Russland
Indien China und die Erweiterung jetzt
die im Juni beschlossen worden ist ein
System ausbildet was sich hauptsächlich
darauf stützt wegzukommen vom Dollar als
als als Hauptwährung in im Welthandel
und andere Pläne gerne umsetzen möchte
auch der regionalen
militärzusammenarbeit und und und dann
ist es nicht verkehrt davon zu sprechen
dass wir große systemische
systemarchitektonische Verschiebungen
haben und dass die Pläne die Donald
Trump zumindest schon ankündigt sowohl
global wie eben auch in der Zersetzung
der eigenen Demokratie für uns in Europa
aber die für die westliche Gemeinschaft
Brand gefährlich sein
würden Frau klü asbru vielen Dank für
ihren Input vielen Dank dass Sie meine
Fragen und die Fragen unserer Community
beantwortet haben alles Gute nach Berlin
sehr sehr gerne danke
schön ja wie es mit der usdemokratie
weitergeht sowohl jetzt bezogen auf
diese Blockade aber auch hinsichtlich
des nächsten Jahres also des Wahljahres
in den USA ihr werdet hier bei ZDF heute
live bestimmt erfahren ich bedanke mich
für eure Fragen und werf zum Schluss
noch mal einen Blick in eure Kommentare
hier schreibt jemand Chaos im Kongress
wird auch weitläufig Auswirkungen auf
den ukrainekrieg haben und Rut Meer auf
Facebook schreibt USA larm gelegt
unfassbar und traurig zugleich dies
sollte uns eine Lehre sein ich bedanke
mich auch für euren Input und wünsche
euch noch einen schönen Abend bis
bald